reading yeah you France the Russian
president ordered massive bombing
strikes ah 1995 close enough to the Cold
War then Hollywood could still get away
with presenting Russia as an aggressive
world military power worthy of concern
hey you wait it appears to be turning
into the worst standoff since the Cuban
Missile Crisis
so there's your ninety second I guess
news broadcast was that live I don't
know all I know is that he was kicked
off the ship for impersonating a news
broadcaster later movie about nuclear
submarines takes its name from a college
sports nickname because SEC bitches wait
wait wait Aragorn and Malcolm X together
at a kid's birthday party I think I just
found my fanfiction niche threatening
nuclear attack oh good more news either
they let the birthday candles and
neglected to have the birthday girl blow
them out or they lit them before the
magic show even began which is way too
early to be lighting birthday candles or
it's possible the prop guy lit them
because he thought it'd make a cool but
a logical shot Michael Bay's Godfather's
hay horses there are fascinating animals
dumbest fence posts but very intuitive
in that way they're not too different
from high school curves they might not
have a brain in their head but they do
know all the boys wanna fuck um who is
fing the horse in the scenario because I
feel like that's a line you've been
dying to say but you worried you never
get a chance to say and then this thing
about horses comes up and you're like
time for my brilliant line about high
school girls Jack Russells smartest dogs
alive but not that intuitive and that
way they're like those nerdy chicks in
AP Calculus I have brains in their heads
but no idea how much the boys want to
also I see someone's never owned a
border collie
I will kill 900,000
of the people who are responsible take
you've seen enough of news broadcasts
most definitely go again commander
hunter just happens to get the XO job on
a submarine where's vest buddy is the
weapons officer and thank God right
movie probably saved a ton of money on
rain machine rental by filming next door
to the Shawshank Redemption set right
when Darabont was filming andy's escaped
microphones hooked up in a downpour
that's a paddlin I didn't know that
being on a submarine called the Alabama
mint also loving the state and being a
fan of their football team how many of
these assholes have ever been to Alabama
um is the Navy still welding pieces of
this submarine in place right before
launch when we're all the sparks coming
from submarine clearly has three
we camouflage fires in this shot but
then later only has one in subsequent
diving shots
Bravo hunter you knew to shut up and
enjoy the view we're stuck just one up a
couple of points 30-year veteran Navy
captain uses arbitrary scoring system
for his new EXO's you want your own boat
someday very worst thing you can do is
worry about yourself or try to impress
me said the guy who just hyped up his
scoring system for subordinate officers
seriously using a men's choir to accent
the action movie wishes it could be the
Hunt for Red October Oh awesome
there in the deeps portion of the
Pacific Ocean and not only that but
there are a multiple amount of deeps
that they are navigating here also in
case you confused it with the Pacific
Ocean shallows the submarine brought a
VHS copy of cliffhanger onboard I'm glad
we're getting the Greenwich Mean Time
for this puts me right in the action I
don't need to think wait is that Oh 400
Eastern Time did I leave the oven on I
better left the oven on holy Sh is that
Ryan Philippi because that guy also
doofus level level sailors allowed to
keep an aquarium with dozens of pet fish
on a submarine because Hollywood worst
cooks ever kickstart a chain of events
so that Hunter and Ramsay can have their
first showdown also Denny's hunter just
happens to be right next to the
firefighter suits when one alarm sounds
which would be a matter of convenience
except for the fact that he doesn't even
take one the next time we see him though
he's got all the gear also why is it
that the TSO yells Barnegat over the
intercom but it takes an alarm to sound
before runners aware of the fire no one
except the new XO knows about the magic
OneTouch button that puts out kitchen
fires you got something to say to me you
say it in private
what the donners say that was so bad in
front of the other men he quietly
reminded the captain that the fire could
flare back up but he didn't say hey
fucktard why are you running a weapons
drill right now by the way was Merritt
Jax 300 pounds that killed him not the
fire
how many heavy people are on this ship
we have a chief of the boat he's a big
dude earlier we saw Bobby
not exactly a paragon of fitness himself
making snide remarks about this guy who
couldn't even do three push-ups also
when you bring up one guy's weight in
the movie and then some other guy dies
because of his weight that tends to be
confusing protagonist takes out his
frustration through boxing cliche he
sends to you to start a drill in the
middle of a 5 no no it does not in fact
I'm surprised the Navy doesn't have
explicit regulations about this kind of
thing
this is 1995 we are well into the
litigious cover-your-ass era
nany's all he's got maybe in that little
is why his wife left him Wow clunky
exposition and a riveting ironing scene
Bravo movie Bravo that he would launch
his land-based nuclear weapons at the
United States and at Japan
movie thinks that it can just sneak
Ricky Schroder past us without us
noticing I mean even this guy's kind of
big you know the Navy will apparently
put 150 pounds on you before he can go
on a mission well I said that the Kobe
Silver Surfer was the only real silver
surfer and that the Mobius Silver Surfer
wish it won't matter which Silver Surfer
is best when you see the movies also I
suppose you don't need a credit Quentin
Tarantino on the script touch up if
you're gonna let him write dialogue that
is so obviously Tarantino ish nailed it
that is how you handle a problem right
there
of course he never goes to talk to the
other guy who was in the fight that guy
can shove whomever he wants and prefer
the Mobius Silver Surfer without any
Ripper man but what is the time boy sure
is a good thing we had that little
Silver Surfer fight a minute ago because
now we're gonna see his character in
action and I wouldn't have given a flank
about this guy if I hadn't seen that
Silver Surfer thing a minute ago set
condition 1sq
about what the fuck is steve zahn doing
they were told a man battle stations and
everybody ran out of the room also isn't
he the same guy who gave orders during
weapons test so when she gets real he
becomes a slacker oh look at Steve Zahn
pretending he's been doing his job the
whole time sad Philip II is sad yet
again manufactured tension between the
two leads coming out of nowhere did
hunter say something completely out of
line this is the reason for ramsey being
a dick we got a limited radio
transmission indicating
I am we need to go shallow to
re-establish communications what else is
he supposed to say and how is he
supposed to say it when our missile
system is ready mr. hunter is my
intention to rise to launch depth while
Jefferson and get the hell out of there
okay so I'm a little confused the whole
reason why you didn't want to go up to
the communications depth was because
there was a Russian sub out there that
could fire at you at any moment
that's why you doped 831 feet but when
rising to launch depth put you in the
same danger also wouldn't rising to
launch depth put you in the position to
get the II am he began the mission at
150 feet and when you started diving to
avoid the Russian sub you started
getting a message so you can apparently
get communications at that depth well
keep looking he's out there looking for
us not necessarily I mean he turned
toward you fired two missiles at you and
you ramped up the speed and made about
as much noise as a sub can make trying
to get away does the other guy not have
sonar did you go dead in the water after
the explosion so that his sonar can't
see you you're telling me this dog was
shut up in this bunk room with a
LITTLEST vole of treats on the desk and
didn't eat them all talk about
threatening the suspension of disbelief
over into clothes how weapons won't have
time off character unnecessarily waste
time explaining things to another
character who should know better anyway
just so the audience can get some cheap
submarine 101 just shoot this ker what's
a thousand yards for as it takes a
thousand yards for the torpedoes to arm
Jesus he jumped take it on this shit I
thoughts exactly and they go double for
that asshat on the bridge a second ago
who was equally clueless about this fact
I say 1,600 feet none of these sailors
is doing anything to help restore the
ship to work in condition this is tragic
and all but someone tell me again why
these three idiots down here didn't just
come up one of them even said it's not
like they didn't know their efforts were
at this point in vain it's not like they
didn't know the water level was rising
and Ricky shorter was yelling for them
comedy power story and some ex machina
guy we didn't get to watch managed to
fix the propulsion just 25 feet from
hole crush depth they should call this
movie convenience tide though is captain
for years and his asshole hunter shows
up which brings up this question why
haven't any of Ramsey's loyal followers
ever been promoted to XO they obviously
have the experience and they know what
kind of man he is and get along with it
maybe Ramsey wouldn't have such a hard
time keeping his second-in-command if he
could hire from within no many checks we
go through to make sure launch orders
authentic well - right
you match the code on the paper to the
code in the safe and and you have the XO
do the same thing really it's one if
we're being honest and it's just that
one being repeated by a second person so
one check you don't put
a condom unless you gotta fuck yeah but
when you're fueling your missiles you
want them to hit the target when you're
putting on a condom you definitely don't
want your missiles to hit the target
also maybe you're putting it on to
demonstrate to someone else the proper
condom application process or maybe
you're a condom model huh ever think of
that
also dude the entire Cold War was
nothing but a series of condom putting
on without fucking did someone to say
something about fucking despite having
no reason at all to turn on his friend
or go against established naval policy
webseries to the mutiny because reasons
yeah better close that door it's not
like people can see or hear you on the
other side until it's all about knowing
this dude okay so his name is Vossler
isn't that the same name that was on the
boxing marquee in Pulp Fiction
Vossler versus Martinez Tarantino you
can't even script doctor without putting
one of your buddy's names in it
well I'm Captain Kirk you're Scotty well
yeah I suppose you don't need a credit
Quentin Tarantino on the script touch up
if you're gonna let him write dialogue
that is so obviously Tarantino ish so
Crimson Tide is the title the plot is
basically two powers alternating turns
on the throne so all I really need to
know is which one's Alabama and which
ones all burn inform your men directly
captain isn't command I have the Conn
attempted mutiny has been put down dude
what's the point of the special order
for them to inform their men directly if
you're just gonna hop on the intercom
and tell everyone at once mr. Zimmer is
the new XO see I mean he's probably not
as good as hunter but he's at least not
gonna make the mistake of being black
Naval assholes are so sloppy they need
two notes to remind them to clean and
this is the officers mess too also it's
your duty to clean exclamation point
coffee pot after you use it that is
definitely one sentence presented it's
too good thing the captain told his
mutiny dudes to clean out the weapons
Locker when they went for firearms oh
wait Ramsay just happens to be walking
underneath Hunter at this very moment so
he can figure out they're going to
missile control well if the movies
trying to make it seem like either guy
could be right this part here kind of
derails that in a huge way also Hackman
just went from kind of a hard-ass
captain who was still not technically
wrong to straight-up dickwad antagonist
in the span of three seconds this shit
fire submarine goes through the Death
Star waiting period in order to get
ready to fire
Conn weapons Russian missiles will have
launch capability in seven minutes
captain radio bossless oh she's
breathing again real really really close
you got three minutes okay so why was
there a rush to launch the missiles that
if you're drawing a line at four total
minutes until the potential Russian
launch
seems like you could had time to get a
simple freakin message back when you had
way more time earlier sure there was a
Russian sub around but you were willing
to go to launch depth so what
speaking of horses never see those
lemons honor stallions well yeah I
suppose you don't need a credit quitting
Tarantino on the script touch-up get
Lipizzaner stallions
most highly trained horses in the world
they're all white that's resistant also
did I miss some racial subtext they took
that subtext right to the text without a
bit of warning did they and at Birth
they're not white black I guess this
means something somehow either black is
better or white is better I can't decide
not nerdy Westergaard Zimmer get that II
am does it require three people to go
get a message Oh screw you
we know the message is to terminate the
launch you know what would have been
amazing if it didn't terminate the
launch see it's possible for Hunter to
still be right but still have to launch
the missiles but the movie has to be
black and white right you see being
right was not what this was about but I
always felt like this was the douchier
move it's like a broadcast of how above
it Hunter is that he's right this guy's
job I'm prepared to make my
recommendations to sub PAC without my
testimony sir if he is lying this will
be the first diver I'm okay but who
cares whether he doesn't lie or not
there's something called bias that
generally gets in the way of the truth
sometimes whether you think you're
telling a hundred percent of the truth
or not you were both right and you were
also both wrong honestly things stacked
the deck so high against Ramses being
right this statement doesn't seem that
truthful it seems like hunter was pretty
much 100% right and Ramsay did
everything he could to avoid being right
in every situation also cop-out endings
suggest you should forget that the
captain put a gun to an innocent sailors
head and also punched his XO in the face
several times be given his next command
at the earliest possible convenience
movie unintentionally inspires the
antagonist gives the protagonist a good
recommendation at the end surprise from
The Devil Wears product more reading
scary reading
passing 1,500 feet in 1850 it's all over
your background is impressive George but
how does it apply to what we do here at
Kruger industrial smoothing little ducks
there's trouble in Russia so they called
us we're going over there Kelly Missy
tonight we skate tonight we stay with
them and we shut them down because we
can I grew up around here my grandfather
took me to fish of that Island right
over there there's one question you
haven't asked me to you can't break me
because you didn't make me you
understand huh set condition 1sq or
significant at 22 24
before we begin captain I'd like to know
exactly what happened to poutine
he didn't sleep on his tee did he I
don't think I like your turn Slevin what
the hell's my tone got to do with it I
just local bagging all we have Joe
Reno's going back did you order the
Cobra god damn right I did
may I have your attention I'm confused
all I hear from you you spineless
cowards is how poor you are now you
can't afford my taxes my protection and
yet somehow you've all managed to find
the money to hire a professional
gunfighter to kill me